we're still here in Belarus there are
plenty of questions about Wagner and
their eventual deployment here
especially after the big conversation we
had with Alexander lukashenko yesterday
do you see the any possibility of a rap
Rushmore between pregosian and the
Kremlin he is free what happens to him
next well things happen in life but if
you think that Putin is so malicious and
vindictive and that he will to say in
plain Russian whack him somewhere
tomorrow no this will not happen we're
at a base which
was speculated to be a home for them but
apparently they haven't made any final
decisions yet we'll bring you all the
latest on Sky News